there are countless Chinatown's all over
the world in New York boasts one of the
most famous full of cheap produce fish
markets and of course a plethora of
Chinese food
but if you hop on the one train take it
to the Upper West Side you'll find a
Chinese restaurant like no other where
half the menu is something else to
ellipta chicha Roland's ropa vieja post
on it ah gross III hold this is la
caridad 78 New York's last Cuban Chinese
restaurant comida China Grill oh yeah
three oh yeah how did this unlikely
culinary duo come to be it's a great
question enter Sam Lee sorry my wife
remember father came over here so he
started I like his own restaurant would
he like open spaces and also the Chinese
put mix together hundreds of thousands
of Chinese came to Cuba in the 19th and
early 20th century establishing a strong
presence on the island but when Castro
came to power most Chinese immigrants
like Sam's father left many of them
coming to the US and thus Cuban Chinese
food was born I would say luckily that
restaurant is not restaurant it's a
kitchen for Upper West siders we have
oxtail robbery ha which is like a
shredded beef at the same time research
Irish food either cooked from my you
know mainly from China and they learn
the train when they got here and it
become very good so are there any Cuban
born workers left I still have a one
kilburn worker working for me
Medina see enemy camino Miyagi my name
is Antonia Wong I work in a career I'm a
stallion 1986 I'm born in a manicure in
1951
and every analyst key one working the
whistle while Cuban Chinese culture is
fading la caridad is a snapshot of a
strange moment in time were to vastly
different cultures merged together the
Cuban Chinese people getting older and
they don't have any younger people to
take over I myself felt like I all my
father who started this restaurant so I
want to try to make sure that I carry on
the tradition for him
[Music]